we might as well get started I was
expecting this room to be full to
brimming but it just hasn't happened so
we're just gonna get rolling and
hopefully we can I don't some of you
guys in the back come on up just let's
get cozy
so today's this is a session if you
don't know where you are you and you
can't read it is AI driven image
captioning for inclusive productivity so
what we're talking about today is
captioning and what we have today is
four fantastic scholars to talk a little
bit about the state of the art and the
space and me to hopefully just
coordinator little bit
so right now PowerPoint has some pretty
amazing things that just come out of the
box you can this is a picture of my
kitten and because the Internet is
really good with cats it actually does a
pretty good job of identifying it
correctly it's a cat lying on the ground
and if you go into a PowerPoint these
days for any image and you look at alt
text it will automatically generate alt
text for your images but sometimes it's
better than others so this is an example
from a study we did a couple of years
ago and for some reason the text is
giant on this but this was a tweet that
was associated with Hillary Clinton back
when she was running for president and
it said some on the other side may say
our best days are behind us let's prove
them wrong and so when we ran this in in
our little study and we did sent this up
to the image captioning this was the
caption it gave us I'm not really
confident but I think it's a man doing a
trick on a skateboard at night now okay
so it's easy to kind of laugh about that
and and but you can imagine that that
also something that people will just
discount immediately because it's
ridiculous that you know this is a hit
this is a the tweet is associated with
let's prove them wrong and it's Hillary
Rodham Clinton so this seems kind of
crazy but yet when we talk to
participants this is one of our
participants she said well if you
say there's an older man on a skateboard
at night that would make more sense
that's the way I take our best days are
behind us because I'm an old lady so
basically this is a blind woman who is
making sense of this caption that was
provided with this tweet basically just
because she needs to try to understand
what it might possibly be so this is an
interesting thing for us this also
points a little bit to the challenges
that we're involved in here right that
that not only do you have to be right
but you need to provide people with at
least a sense of I mean we say I'm not
confident in the in the caption but
people still believe it so there's
another problem which is how do you do
captioning for something like this the
auto description by PowerPoint this is a
really famous information infovis thing
from a map showing Napoleon's Russian
campaign and it's showing all kinds of
things at once so how can you imagine
providing a caption for something like
that or even just a simple line graph
for that matter if that's usable the
auto description on this is close-up
image of a map there's some other ways
you can go about this and this is some
work that we've done in our group so the
alt text on this image is this
ridiculous thing here this h3 FS 0 X
yada yada yada jpg now we had an idea
that there are other captions out in the
world that we can suck in and explore
for this and so this was some work that
we did where if you go out onto the web
and you do image search and you match
those images there are a lot of images
that appear other places that are well
captioned so using something like our
caption crawler technology we can show
that it's an Antarctic volcano Mount
Erebus seen over NASA this is actually a
pretty good caption I mean so we get
that from elsewhere this is not this is
sort of symbiotic mated in a way so what
we're going to think about today are
some of that what I think of is some of
the big problems and
think these are shared by most of our
panelists if not then that's even better
is how our people who are blind or low
vision engaging with the digital images
today look what are they actually doing
and what do they want to do with this
content and what kinds of algorithmic
and interactive approaches are gonna
actually get us to let them be able to
do those things and what do we need to
do to train our models what kind of data
do we need in order to get there and
finally how do we know if we get there
what what what kind of metrics do we
actually need in order to understand
this so I think these are a lot of
really big deep problems in the state of
the art with an image captioning that
hopefully we can start to talk a little
bit about today so in order to do that
we have four amazing scholars and we
will start with I'm gonna move back to
our things so you can see the order it's
there so we're going to start with
doneger re she's at the University of
Texas she's actually been associated
collaborating with us a little bit on
some recent work and she'll hopefully
talk a little bit about that
Kathleen McCoy from the University of
Delaware walter Lisicki University of
Michigan and then we'll wrap up with a
check mark here at MSR AI and then God
willing we will have lots of time for
questions after that to really start to
engage with all you guys so with that I
will shut up and turn this over to Donna
are you plugging in or are you okay
splendid
all right can you hear me okay okay
great um so it's pleasure to be here
today my name is Donna kirari and I'm
going to share about our team's work on
describing images taken by people who
are blind so describing images such as
this one with a caption such as two
t-shirts one white the other black
hanging in a closet or answering visual
questions such as which shirt is black
answer is on the right may seem trivial
to many of you but for people who are
blind such tasks are obstacles that can
significantly impede them in their daily
lives there's an estimated 39 million
million people worldwide who are blind
of note many people go blind later in
life so each of you may be concerned
both for yourselves and people you know
in fact 82 percent of all people who are
blind are 50 years and older so nearly
10 years ago a mobile phone application
called viswas was released to help
people who are blind get descriptions of
their images with this application a
user could double click on the phone to
take an image then double click on the
phone to record a question about the
image and then have those both sent to a
team of people who in turn would either
provide a caption or an answer since
that application emerged it inspired a
number of other applications to emerge
to do similar thing of returning a
caption or provided an answer to a
visual question and the commonality is
that there is a reliance on on remote
humans to provide answers of note this
idea has also been done using glasses
where there's a camera sitting on the
glasses as well the limitation is that
these applications rely on humans which
means they can be more costly they can
be slower response times and they also
lead to privacy issues so the aim of our
group is to teach computers to
automatically describe any image and I
emphasize including from real users eye
people who are blind so in this talk I
will talk about to the contributions I
have come to our from our research group
the first is an infrastructure for
empowering AI community to create
algorithms that assist real users of
visual assistance technology and the
second is to discuss some new difficult
AI challenges that were inspired by real
users data so diving into the first
topic just some background I think we
have an interdisciplinary group so I
just want to talk about how doing
nowadays teach computers to do a task so
the typical approach is to train using
as many labeled examples as possible so
think about how you would teach for
example a child to recognize a person
the intuition of how we teach is we
might show an example of an image with a
person and say this is a person but we
would probably show many examples so
that a child learns that there are
people of different colors shapes sizes
configurations and so on this is the
same situation we have when we teach a
black box which I show here to represent
any kind of algorithm so with algorithms
the goal is also to provide as many
training examples as possible so an
exciting aspect of what I've been
talking about is that the AI community
has already been trying to teach
computers to describe images for image
captioning this started back in 2006
with the first publicly available data
set had twenty thousand examples in it
and over time the size of that data set
has grown to be hundreds of thousands of
examples this is also true for the
visual question-answering task where the
first public data set emerged in 2014
and has grown all the way up to over a
million examples in recent years the
problem with existing data sets though
is that they are a mismatch from what is
going on with real users today so if you
look at the way existing datasets have
been created the pictures and questions
come from different people or
automatically generated typically these
questions are scraped from online from
photo sharing websites such as Flickr so
lots of them are high quality images
they're also typically scraped along
certain theme like does it contain a dog
a person and so on the questions are
also contrived again they come from
someone else typically this is a hired
crowd worker to make up an interesting
question or from an algorithm that makes
up an interesting question in reality
when we look at a real use case of these
of the desire for these services the
same person is both taking the picture
and asking the question and moreover the
data is reflecting real users interests
so our approach for creating an
infrastructure to empower the AI
community in creating algorithms to
describe images taken by real users is
twofold first is we created the
infrastructure which is a big label data
set second is we figured out how to
scale in order to involve a larger
community so we can accelerate progress
on this important problem so for the
first task of creating the big label
data set again we took advantage of that
bhisma's mobile phone application I
described at the start it was used
between 2011 and 2015 over 11,000 people
submitted over 70,000 requests to that
application um we in recent years
grabbed about for almost 45,000 of those
where users agreed to share their data
to support research and of note about
15% of those images that are included in
that data set were requests for just
captions not answers to visual questions
this is data from real users so it's
very important to protect their privacy
and anonymity so the first step we did
is we transcribe the questions to remove
people's voices we also received any in
all the images to remove any metadata
such as GPS location indicating where
persons at we then had in-house people
filter all the images for any personally
identifying information finally we did
data labeling in order to collect
high-quality captions and answers that
could be used to support our AI
challenge
in total our data sets are we have two
data sets that we are publicly releasing
the first one has over 30,000 image
question pairs with over 300,000
crowdsource answers the second one has
over 39,000 images with almost 200,000
captions of them and so this is the
first data set where real users
requested image captions as well as
answers to their visual questions to
support the real daily needs if we look
at how hard is this data set for
existing state of art algorithms we find
that existing algorithms perform poorly
on this data set I show here some
examples for visual question answering
and for captioning and in general we
want to see scores close to 1 and we are
far from that so this is a difficult
challenge for the AI community as of
when we release the datasets and this is
just an example to show where these
algorithms fall short you have an image
here where the captioning system says a
man is holding his head on a cell phone
so that's inspiration for an AI
community they want hard problems we
created a hard problem coming from real
users data so next thing was how to
scale first step is we shared our
dataset it is publicly available you
today can go to viswas org and find it
and so currently the visual
question-answering data set is out we
will be releasing the image captioning
data set soon along with some other
label data sets of note
others are also sharing the data set
since we released it it was ingested
into academic torrents Kaggle and
recently Facebook's platform to
encourage the design of multimodal
algorithm design to track progress we
also provided a public evaluation server
with leaderboard where people who are
competing to try to do well on our tasks
can see where's their rank amongst
people internationally who are competing
we also organized an event to foster
community and celebrate progress back in
20:18 in germany and we plan to continue
to do so and this is this brought
together researchers both from industry
and practitioners and sorry
practitioners in industry and
researchers from academia to speak about
the space and this progress has been
celebrated around the world people are
blogging about it and we've had articles
coming out all the way out in South
Korea in Europe and we have others
celebrating on Malta on public media
about the successes of progress on this
important problem so to summarize we
created a big data we figured out half
scale the community is still actively
working on this problem but the problems
not yet solved and so I'd like to talk a
little bit about what makes this problem
hard so to dive into the next
contribution of our group I'll talk
about new difficult AI challenges that
are inspired by real users data so to
recap we began with almost 45,000
requests from users where they agreed to
share their data and of course we and I
thought we went through an autumn izing
the data filtering out private
information and labeling all the data so
one of the key challenges we found is
that the images are in adequate quality
this isn't quite surprising people who
are blind can't necessarily verify the
quality of the images they're taken so
we found that 9% of over 39,000 images
have quality issues that are so severe
that you can't recognize the content and
describe it we found that 29% of over
30,000 visual questions aren't answered
for example what is the expiration date
it's not shown in the image similarly
what is this a gift card for what
temperature is the dial set to
so important AI challenges include
guiding users to take high quality
images and also to help them capture the
content of interest in their images
another important challenge that emerged
is how to deal with private content we
found that 12% of over of almost the
45,000 images are showing private
content content includes things like
faces credit cards pregnancy tests
computer screens prescription pills and
many more described in the publication
at the bottom of the screen and of these
privacy disclosures 16% of those
examples were intentional questions such
as what is the medicine in this pill
bottle were included moreover one out of
every 40 visual questions that were
asked with the app we're asking about
private information such as pregnancy
tests pill bottles letters and street
signs so another a I challenge is how do
we create big data of private content to
teach algorithms and also how do we
develop algorithms that can analyze
private content and the third key
challenge that we observed is that
there's a diversity of practical
interests so here I show a distribution
of all the questions that were asked in
the publicly available visual question
data set key questions that emerge are
what is this what is in this can what
does this say and what color is this
zooming in from that we found that 53%
of the questions involve reading text so
things like could you please tell me
what's in the can
what are the directions for someone who
is 10 years old do I have to hit
anything any keen combination to make it
work where the last example is someone
installing a Microsoft on their computer
we also found that 28% of the questions
involves recognizing color such as is
this shirt clean or dirty what color is
my shirt does the pant in this shirt
match and can it be worn together so
another a I challenge is describing
images by analyzing text and recognizing
color so summarize some of the new
difficult AI challenges that we observed
from the data we see that systems need
to deal with inadequate images private
content and text and color analysis so
to summarize really users of visual
assistance technology are sharing their
data to help the research community make
progress on problems that matter to them
in their daily lives
we took their data and packaged it into
a challenge that's available for the AI
community to work on real use cases and
progress is being made today
moreover the data set is highlighting
new important problems such as dealing
with in equit images private content and
text analysis there are many people to
acknowledge some of you are in the room
there's the team that built these data
sets there's also the team that built
the application for the vizwiz system
help in crowdsourcing and design help in
developing our evaluation server there's
all the people who use the business
application there's the over 1600 crowd
workers who helped to label our data and
others in the room so what are some next
steps everything we're doing is with the
hope to inspire our community and we are
publicly sharing all the data this is a
visualization of a tool we built for
everyone in the room to use to browse
the data set you can see that we're
browsing through a bunch of visual
questions with the captions and moreover
you can search on words that are in the
visual question words that are in the
caption words that are in the answer
and more so you can get a glimpse of the
data set we also invite you to advance
the design of AI algorithms we currently
have two challenges that are available
for the community and we have more
coming soon so thank you very much for
your time
[Applause]
yes thank you for great work is
certainly very interesting I'm
especially interested in the mention of
the privacy you say do you have created
a new version of data set with privacy
content a intentional and unintentional
privacy classification but that's not
it's not entirely clear to me how you're
gonna take advantage of the privacy
information are you trying to persuade
to those blind users not to upload those
privacy images oh it's like like any
kind of a suggestion of visual
assistance regarding when regarding the
privacy sharing how you gonna use the
privacy to annotations so privacy is so
important right we're seeing over one
out of ten of the privacy disclosures
12% of the images have privacy
information so we must as a community
deal with this to make people feel safe
and trusting of the technology so now
the question is how do we make progress
without requiring people to share their
information so one of the key findings
of the work we did and there's a lot
more of a discussion is we show that you
actually don't need private information
to make an algorithm that can detect
automatically private content and image
what we did with the data set we
publicly released is we actually removed
the regions of private information from
every image and only preserve the
context we tried using different
inpainting algorithms and that's an
expertise we have in-house in our team
is designing algorithms to try to
generate fake content in images and we
found that using these images where we
wipe out only the private regions and
put in some fake content is useful for
training algorithms to recognize private
information and other in novel new
images yeah agree and I think it makes
sense if we just wanted to detect
occurrence of the privacy regions the
images and contacts the information
where to and the generation models will
help I'd I can that all those make sense
to me but my confusion is so now you
have a model that can detect the privacy
attribute like existing on all uploaded
image I
how you gonna take advantage of yet when
you use that the trainer model are you
trying to persuade the users not to
upload an image when the image are taken
with privacy or what what yeah okay so
there's what I think is the immediate
solutions and then there's the long-term
dream the immediate is in the work that
we show we we put out there the idea of
just recognizing does an image have
private information or not if the answer
is yes you probably want to notify the
user about that because often it's
unintentional right so that's the first
user experience task we can do the
second user experience task you can
imagine is we have an image and a
question about the image so the next
step is to detect whether the person
intended to share that private
information and if we say and we showed
some algorithms we showed promising
results that show yes algorithms can
understand the intent from the question
in the image and in that case then you
can think about having those visual
questions sent out to a secured more
expensive trusted crowd right so you can
imagine creating tears our locals are
rare even without ascending at exactly
but then the dream of course that I have
is that we start to figure out how to
automatically generate fake looking
images so we can start to figure out how
to design algorithms to just not have
humans in the loop be able to design
algorithms to handle that private
information entirely and I think the
step for that is creating fake images
and that's something that the computer
vision community is making great
progress on and I think it's viable in
the future makes a lot of this thank you
very much ok everybody hear me okay so I
am Kathy McCoy I'm professor and chair
of computer science at the University of
Delaware where I have specialized in the
area of natural language generation and
also accessibility for people with
disabilities I'm also a technical
consultant fern idler National Institute
on disability independent living and
rehabilitation research which is part of
the US Department of Health and Human
Services the reason why that's relevant
is because I dabble a little bit in sort
of policy types of
issues that are involved with the
government for a good number of years I
have been looking at trying to create a
textual summary of an information
graphic an information graphic is
something like a a bar chart or a line
graph and what I'm showing up on the
screen are a couple of multimodal
documents that you might pick up on the
web and you can see in the screen on on
the screen that there are some line
graphs in there now the interesting
thing in studying these line graphs or
well these kinds of information graphics
that occur in articles that we see those
graphics may or may not even be talked
about in the article and certainly the
main reason why they are there they're
there for a communicative intent that
the author has and wants you to get out
of it if we don't do something to allow
people who are blind or visually
impaired to have access to them they're
losing out on that information and so I
wanted to find out what could we do
typically accessibility for people who
are blind or visually impaired they use
screen readers and screen readers can
easily provide text that you have in a
document has no clue what to do with an
image for the most part we've already
heard some of the things we can do alt
text is you know you're it's supposed to
be there it's often missing or it's
completely misleading and one question
that I've had is what should this alt
text contain anyway for these kinds of
graphics the law the were you know
federal guidelines say well just you
know if you have a graph of some time
put the data in there well I'm sorry
that doesn't work right the whole reason
why there's a picture is because it does
something it tells us something that's
really what we want to capture and
besides alt text is not at all
possible if we've got big data sorry but
putting the data in is not at all
possible
well alt text at all for big data or
dynamically generated visualizations and
these things are really important so
what do we do well we had this site
project that has been like 15 years in
the making and our hypothesis was in
this that what we wanted to do was to
put in the alt text what someone who was
sighted would get out of a casual look
all right of it and we thought that this
was the most important message and I'll
tell you a little bit more about what we
mean by that and then also some salient
visual features let me see so some
important messages the important message
of a graph particularly a line graph it
has something to do with the data in the
graph but it also has something to do
with what the the author may decorate
that graph with call-out boxes and
things like that that that can alter
that but it's basically what's the trend
doing for a line graph increasing
decreasing changing etc so we thought
that that was the most important sort of
thing to put in a graph and what I've
shown here for example the I have a
graph up I'm going to put more graphs up
because it'll be easier what we have on
the left is a graph that the looks like
it is there's a bit of a stable trend
and then there's a rising trend to be
honest if I look at this graph I see
more of a rising trend but why do I
think that it's actually a stable trend
followed by a rise it's because the
author also called something out to us
on this graph this 1.79
it calls out the beginning of the graph
and the end of the graph not didn't put
something in the middle where it you
know it was flat and then it goes up it
called out the whole thing
so that that I think has something to do
with even though that first part is
smaller why it's probably important
anyway hurry hurry
so there there's another stable and a
fall and then there's a rise enough fall
we think that's the backbone of what
ought to be in a graph in in a summary
in a summary but there ought to be more
and we tried to get people to give us
you know write some summaries of graphs
of what's going on in a couple of things
popped up so the graph on the left it is
highly volatile it's really jagged that
kind of thing is usually mentioned if
it's there the annotations tell us
something we've got to recognize that
the second graph is really smooth you
might write you might say something
about that the third graph is really
steep so things like steepness and
things like that might occur this we can
all get out of the vision component so
we actually the generation person to me
was really interested in making nice
beautiful text I think we did a pretty
good job so here's an example the image
shows a line graph which presents IRS as
percentage of returns he filed the line
graph shows a rising trend from 1996 to
2005 the rising trend has a starting
value of twelve point six percent in an
ending value of 51.1% beautiful right is
it good is it useful well that's an
important question so we did evaluate
and the question is how do we evaluate
what's going on here and again well the
way that we want to evaluate it is can
people who are visually impaired get out
of it what what someone who is sighted
would get out of it so we figured oh
well what they really ought to do is can
they answer questions about it the most
important things that you get from a
graphic now I just have to point out
maybe we can all figure this out
ourselves I can't be the one to make up
the questions because I made up a system
right that's cheating so we had to
collect some questions and then we also
had to make sure that we feel
to them because they couldn't have
domain information all of that stuff you
could really get from a graph anyway so
that in itself is important but that's
the key why is it that we're doing this
what is it that we want to be able to
get out of it and I think that's a lot
of the message that we've already heard
our system did pretty well if I do say
so myself however it was it was really
broken in a lot of ways because we
didn't really have a vision component
that could give us all of the pieces
that we needed in order to do this and
my colleague in the room and Kim over
here heard me talk once and he said hey
wait what wait I I'm a vision person
can't we learn just learn how to go from
the graph to the text and I said no we
can't I
it's too hard how how are we going to do
it and so we had to negotiate some we
did want to use supervised deep learning
all right we need lots and lots of
training data we didn't have the
training data we need neural network all
right so what we decided to do instead
of doing this one-shot deal what we're
doing is a little dance between the
vision and the and the generation and it
also made the the training data
significantly easier to acquire so we
acquired some training data from
Mechanical Turk and rather than having
people give us whole summaries what we
tried to do was to get people to give us
that the pieces of information that we
needed in order to build the summary and
so things like so there's a graph up at
the top this is what one of the the
heads would look like we asked them
things like what's represented on the
x-axis we have to generate that what's
represented on the y-axis what's the
title what's the primary trend category
so that they could give us that
information and then we could learn
those pieces of it we
there's one thing that I wanted to put
up with this architect the only reason I
put this up was so that we found out
that it's not just the image that's
important when we're trying to learn
this stuff but we've got to pull the
words out separately and reason on them
separately so we actually have to sort
of streams going in I'm showing now an
example of what we have been able to
generate to date this graph titled cost
to sequence a human genome USD shows a
falling trend in millions over years the
x-axis goes from 2001 to 2017 the y-axis
goes from a hundred to a hundred million
the end of the graph continues to fall
on the graph shows a few fluctuations so
now you may have noticed I don't know if
you notice but there are these abcdefgh
IJ in there those are the pieces that
the vision system pulled out and then
what we're doing is putting those pieces
in right now we're putting them together
and not such a it's just a
template-based generator I imagine that
that templates based generator might get
a lot more sophisticated you know as as
we go on in time all right okay
there are some just some other examples
I don't think that's super important now
so where are we well we're still
extracting stuff from graphs and we're
getting ready for an evaluation of this
system with the the latest thing to see
and and we're grappling with how are we
going to set up that evaluation to make
sure that we're on the right track and
that we're giving something that's
really important I just wanted to finish
with a quote from one of my favorite
philosophers Yogi Berra who is an
exceptional catcher for the Yankees and
what I've got on the screen is a picture
of Yogi Berra and a batter who just
bunted a foul ball pretty
I in the air and Yogi's got his eye on
that ball he's thrown off his mask and
trust me he catches it right and the
favorite quote that I like is you've got
to be very careful if you don't know
where you're going because you might not
get there and that's my you know sort of
lesson that I think that we've got to
think about when we're thinking about
problems of accessibility we've got to
figure out where we need to go in order
to make things accessible otherwise we
might not get there we might have very
nice systems but they might not be doing
what we need them to do so I'd like us
all to keep our eye on the accessibility
ball so thank you
[Applause]
to reminder we're gonna hopefully have
plenty of time for questions at the end
them down alright good to go alright so
I'm Walter Lusaka from the University of
Michigan and I'm gonna be talking about
a little bit of why this is hard so I
woke up this morning and I thought to
myself will I have anything to say after
Donna gives an awesome talk and she did
give an awesome talk but I will have a
couple things left to try to draw
distinctions from between classes of
problems and why some of this is hard
but I am here to make sure that we get
time for the panel at the end so this
will be a little bit quicker if you saw
my other talk this morning you've seen
this slide before this is a kind of bit
of background on what my lab and I work
on we think a lot about how to scaffold
interactive intelligent systems in a way
that will allow human intelligence to
fill in the gaps where automated systems
might not be capable of making the
entire experience work for a user and
this includes things like accessibility
applications including visual
question-answering
so we think about trying to get things
deployable robust and work every time
even if it's not necessarily automated
every single time so we not only come up
with new methods for organizing
real-time groups we also think about how
to fill in in new ways and even start
training these systems in richer ways
than we currently have this means I can
teach a rule to the system more
efficiently so we've thought a lot about
how to build systems that answer visual
questions so you want to start with just
a really simple example so we talked
about image labeling in both of the
prior talks
how would you label this image I'm also
here to make sure everybody's still
awake how would you just label this
image if you if you just needed to give
a you know one or two word caption this
no not a full description
benches in a park right so we might have
Park I don't have my preview here maybe
maybe something that mentions the cannon
that seems like a very clear visual
features feature you might also want
some information about information
that's not directly contained in the
image so it turns out this is a park in
Buffalo it's a rainy day right something
about the the weather right you can't
necessarily see that it is you know it's
not currently raining but it's probably
all rainy day right so even just at the
couple of words level we can want a lot
of different information from this image
and it gets even harder if you want to
be able to do visual question-answering
which is what viswas which it was
initially designed to do and you know
eventually results in this very
interesting data set that we can use to
train AI systems but now I can start to
ask things as a user like do you see the
cannon so maybe that's a ironically that
covers up the cannon but you see the
cannon so maybe that's a landmark that
I'm looking for I'm supposed to meet
somebody by the cannon at noon or are
there open benches so this is kind of a
state of the world thing if people are
sitting in all of the seats then maybe I
know I don't need to walk all the way
across the path here I could also ask
questions that may not might not
actually make sense in a particular
scene so text wrapping aside do you see
any where to park so maybe you know your
friends coming to meet you there they
need to park somewhere but there's no
parking lot here that's not a question
that I can necessarily answer right so
it gets Messier and Messier as we go and
there's a bunch of other information
that I might want from this visual scene
so it's not that there's one simple
answer that I could learn you can
imagine Park is reasonable if I just
want to label it's not true if I have to
pair this with natural language
information and the richer the question
the more complicated this gets
maybe you even have tailored information
so do you see my friend I don't know
what your friend looks like even if you
say do you see someone wearing a red
shirt right now I need to pick that
feature based on the the language that
was used and this is gonna be a
relatively rare question nobody else is
looking for your friend right so we're
not going to have a million examples of
answers for that at any point okay so
the solution that was proposed by Bigham
at all was to use people and so this
works pretty well in fact it is how we
can get to at scale datasets answering
tens of thousands of questions for real
users so I'm so I'm going to push on
that a little bit more I'm not here to
necessarily take the person out of it
just yet I actually wanna make the
argument that we need to keep people in
these systems for a little bit longer so
crowd worker is usually behind the
scenes in this case but we can do that
in real time so if you imagine a setting
like this where I have a store shelf
with lots and lots of different items
again we can get these relatively
complicated to answer questions like
where's the the hot salsa so necessarily
you know I don't want mild it's not what
I'm here for
well so now I need to find a type of
object I need to locate where it is and
I need to find information on that
object in order to answer this question
and it actually turns out to be a
sequential task because I might not be
able to see that label I should don't
know where this also is on here there
what's something like that so now we
have this problem of framing the
information and so the nine percent of
yzma's images that don't contain
anything useful and a lot of those cases
what you have is someone who who didn't
quite capture either the right side of
the object they blurred information they
miss framed the object so that it wasn't
actually in the scene well enough to to
capture the right information so we did
some work assets 13 that looked at how
you could you build an interactive
system that in real time could respond
to follow-up questions so now I can
take an object easier to take one object
than a shelf and I could say you know
let's see if I can how much sodium okay
this is a terrible example but it's what
I have how much sodium is in this
package so they frame the information
incorrectly right the front label it's
not actually particularly useful in
figuring out how much sodium if it
wasn't water so what you want is
feedback that says well rotate the
bottle a little bit zoom in okay now I
can give you the answer to your question
so you you need interaction as a way to
access this information that's not
immediately available from a single
image you need to give feedback and
guidance to the the end-user themselves
it's the same thing for a lot of fine
grained information that's not
immediately accessible
what's serving size things like that
okay this gets even harder when we go to
sequential interaction settings or
interaction settings that are
necessarily sequential so here I don't
have all of the information that I might
want I as a student you might go to this
web page and say well how do I check my
admission status that's actually an
information navigation task I need to be
able to click on a good starting point
that is not clearly defined from the
question itself and then I need to be
able to follow a reasonable set of kind
of inferred connections to navigate
through the menus so this gets really
really messy and at this point we're
down the how many times does this get
asked maybe I can answer the admissions
question but something like how do I
sign up for courses might be a rare
question that's rarer because you don't
actually do that from this page right so
you need to know that there is no answer
here so there's a lot of subtlety here a
person could do this relatively easily
they could click around a little bit in
fact that's exactly what they do
visually you get a lot of information at
a time about where a certain
functionality might lie and then you
navigate based on that so Steve Oni and
others including myself built this
system for whis 2018 that actually
allows you to call on a remote helper so
worker recruited on-demand from the web
and help complete a navigation task or
identify that this is not something that
can be done from the current page so you
can go you can in real time go get a bit
of human feedback exactly when we don't
know and we can use that to automate the
system so this helps us handle the long
tail problem where there's going to be a
lot of rare queries that we haven't
necessarily heard the more complex the
interaction the more complex the setting
the the thinner and thinner our data set
gets for a large percentage of questions
and this is kind of two of the hardest
problems that we know about at the same
time right it's not just that we have to
understand complex visual scenes but
that context changes based on the
natural language query of the use case
that we have in each setting so the hope
is that kind of going back to this idea
of scaffolding we have a automated
system that wants to answer a question
it's missing some piece of information
it doesn't understand either if it has
the right answer or which part of the
scene is supposed to be relevant to to
answering the query so you can actually
in real time call on human assistants
get a response and eventually what we
want is that the the people giving this
response are able to convey as much as
possible about their model of the world
how they understand both the question
that was asked and the visual scene and
how it might contain answers to that
question and then the hope is that by
doing this repeatedly now we can deploy
systems that learn in the wild and don't
fail for users even the first time the
system experiences a given class of
questions all right so the takeaway
there is visual crash answering is hard
but I think we can get farther with
human back systems actually you know the
downstream effect of that is exactly
what Donna talked about earlier we can
even get these datasets that turn into
challenge problems for the AI community
so thanks
[Applause]
okay this is the right one hey everybody
I'm the last one nobody wanted to be the
last one so here I am I'm giving the
last stop my name is Ajay Kumar I'm a
researcher in MSR AI and today after
hearing these talks that are very
focused on image captioning I'm gonna
try to go one level up and talk about
what do we mean by AI systems function
in the world how can we build reliable
AI systems and I'm gonna try to use
image captioning as a case study to
convey some of the high level messages
I've been thinking about so every AI
talk starts with a slide like this he
basically celebrate a lot of the
advances we had in the neural networks
image multimodal language tasks and we
compare the machine performance to the
human performance and say that AI is
doing great and from these results we
started seeing a lot of AI technologies
being applied in many real-world
settings from like recidivism decisions
in US courts healthcare self-driving
cars and so forth however when we look
into experiences of people in these
real-world domains we see that that
perfect story of numbers going up do not
necessarily translate to the experiences
of people in the real world the one on
the left
I'm sure how many of you have seen this
gorilla example from Google around half
so when Google released their first
image captioning which was just giving a
very short description for the images
these on the bottom middle part you will
see that these two African American
teenagers gave their picture to the
system and the system recognize them as
gorillas on the right we see these cases
of self-driving cars causing harm for
people so what we are seeing case after
case is that AI systems are not perfect
they are far from being perfect they
make mistakes the kind of mistakes they
make have different consequences for our
society depending on the context and the
use case they impact people's lives
why this is happening why me looking so
I'm an AI research world I spent a lot
of my time thinking about these kind of
machine learning pipelines when we look
into these pipelines we see that the
current practice of developing machine
learning systems is that people get
their favorite data set chomp it up into
a training portion and a test portion
build their fabulous big mini layered
models in some cases from that training
data
evaluated in the same in the testator
that come from the same distribution as
the training day that they look at these
aggregate numbers like accuracy they say
we are doing great however there is a
gap between this training pipeline and
the experiences we have in the real
world why water talked about a few of
them real world has a lot of outlier
cases real world has a lot of complexity
and user expectations may not match the
objective functions we are using in
training our models so we taught how can
we actually explore some of these
problems and can we use image captioning
as a case that if we're doing that so
this is what we did two years ago with
Mary Morris and our with our intern and
we looked into image captioning people
have talked about image captioning
machines look at a picture and try to
generate a short one sentence
description of what they see in the
image and there has been data cells like
Coco that has been really like a big
fool for the machine learning community
to focus on this image captioning
challenge this became a celebrated
widely widely used widely studied
problem in the machine learning
community and then this is a paper this
is a figure from one of the papers 2016
paper from Microsoft that actually
compared human captions with the Blues
on blues course the machine captions and
actually say that there is a large
portion of the instances where the
machine that's so good they actually do
better than humans and encouraged from
these results Microsoft released
image captioning as a cognitive service
that you can find today on the website
and
Hooper's are actually using these
captioning services today so we really
wanted to understand how much value
these existing online captioning
services can provide for people and to
study this we looked into captioning
images that are shared on social media
why social media because first of all
helping people with disabilities
visually blind people has been the
number one motivating example that all
of these captioning people use you know
in their papers when they are promoting
the work on image captioning they say we
are very excited that these technologies
can be used to support visually impaired
paper people in their daily lives so we
said let's see let's see how much they
are actually getting to this call and a
good source of data and good platform to
actually study this is social media
because Ed's and Mary's work and others
have shown that a lot of the content
shared on social media I think a billion
a day or something like that actually
contains images and because these tweets
for example or other con other content
don't have alt text in them visually
impaired people cannot access this and
image captioning could be a great tool
for them to understand what is going
going on in in social media so that's
what we wanted to focus on this domain
and social media is really interesting
it is really giving you that real world
context real world use case there is a
lot of variety different different types
of images different conditions people's
expectations could be different in terms
of how much level of detail they are
expecting to get out of the captions or
theirs
maybe they really want to understand the
tweet so that they can decide to comment
on it or retweet it take actions on it
and the level of information they may
need to be able to carry out those
actions is not maybe what we are
training our machine learning models to
do and also mistakes could be costly in
these domains because if like the
Hillary Clinton example that was shown
before
showed before if I look at that as a
visually impaired person I look at it
and I really try and I really create a
meaning out of that and I really believe
in what I'm getting and I actually
comment on it assuming that my
understanding is correct I can't really
make a fool out of myself I can't really
take the wrong action and say the wrong
thing and the research questions we
studied in this work were how much value
people are visually impaired people are
getting from these services today can be
develop hybrid intelligence approaches
approaches that combine machines and
humans together to eliminate or overcome
some of the reliability issues that what
tomato systems have and from the data we
are getting from these human-in-the-loop
approaches can we come to workflows that
are more structured so that they can be
generalizable across different use cases
and finally can we drive the realizable
lessons about how we should be
developing reliable AI systems so in
this work we looked into different kind
of workflows the first one being that
just use the Machine and then be
incorporated more and more human
feedback and hop into the process so
when you look into this image it is from
Time magazine and saying it's about the
Egypt crash when we give this image to
the caption bar it is saying that a man
is sitting on a table when we put human
correction into it this is the simplest
human incorporation and just give this
caption to human and ask for human to
correct it we are getting a bit better
but it still doesn't have the amount of
detail that a human may need to be able
to make sense of the tree Danny actually
moved into more sophisticated support
from the human were repaired a human
being with the visually impaired human
to have a conversation about the image
and the caption BOTS answer so that
conversation helps but it doesn't really
help much if the initial caption is
wrong because the human can get into
this such a bad understand
space that even a full support from a
human cannot get them out of that
misunderstanding space and finally we
looked into some more structured
workflows that are easier to scale and
we have an evaluation framework you can
see it in the paper but we saw some very
clear messages from this first one the
amount of value humans got out of these
captioning systems were very limited and
in some cases the misunderstandings the
incorrect captions provided from these
systems could get the people to such a
bad place that regardless how much help
they were having from humans and hybrids
were closed they couldn't get out of it
so it was very important to provide
correct answers early on so that they
don't get into that bad space and any
form of human-in-the-loop contribution
helped in any of these workflows and we
also validated these results with real
visually impaired users back in the day
so how do we actually build better AI
system that's kind of the question of
the day in my opinion first of all we
need to acknowledge that the kind of the
training flows people study machine
learning people study is not how these
systems are developed in reality should
function in the world reality in reality
and how they should be evaluated in fact
for many AI systems air systems are
developed by people the data is coming
from people people are putting objective
functions creating the experiences
thinking really carefully about how this
machine learning model should be used in
an existing application then there are a
lot of human decisions that go into
building the machine learning model and
we don't have to put the machine
learning model without any human control
in many cases some human-in-the-loop
approach at least in the initial
deployment phase like a soft launch
phase can be actually very powerful to
know first to ensure that our systems
are working reliably but also to collect
importing feedback loops about how our
system is function
so that we can do good assessments and
also continuous improvement for our
systems and finally what matters for
these systems is not these accuracy
numbers or blue scores are mature scores
that are celebrated in the communities
but it's actually the human value how
much value humans are getting out of it
so I just wanted to finish my part of
the session with a few high-level kind
of lessons I got from this study and
other studies I I see first of all I
think as a community we should build not
what is easy or available but what is
useful for our users so we should not be
attracted to these existing data sets
and aggregate metrics and just celebrate
those numbers we should through the look
into the real experience the value that
people get out of this and to be able to
do this I think we should focus on this
development pipeline for AI systems from
design to data collection to model
development to evaluation and ask the
right questions why are we building this
machine learning model or the
integrative system what value do we
expect people to get out of this what
kind of an experience do we need to
ensure reliability and value for people
what are the benefits and risks of the
systems we are developing and what kind
of mitigation strategies we should do
all up into the system so that some
negative consequences could be
eliminated are we collecting the right
data do we have the right objective
function and also are we monitoring what
these systems do in the real world
second we need to really build these
virtuous feedback loops for the systems
we are developing for different use
cases we should collect data about human
experiences you really use that feedback
and maybe the human in the loop feedback
to continuously improve our systems so
this is something that we've been
focusing a lot in our in our group in
the last few years across many different
datasets on machine learning models we
see that correct perfect data sets never
exist it is always the case that our
data sets
broken in some way some important use
case or a work or a user group is
excluded out this is why in many cases
we are seeing blind spots biases in
machine learning models for example when
a certain group of users are not
represented in the data set it is not
surprising that our models and show
biases show lower performance for some
group of users when we look into
formulate this it is actually very clear
this is coming from blind spots in their
assets and in recent work that Mary
Morris is leading
we've been looking into different AI
scenarios this is just a thought
experiment looking into different AI
scenarios and trying to figure out what
kind of biases may be hidden in existing
AI systems for the disabled populations
if you have if you are deaf if you're
blind if you have some certain disease
should we should can usually expect
satisfactory service from AI algorithms
because it is very likely that our
current data sets do not have sufficient
representation from all of these groups
and also our techniques in the AI world
may actually make the situation worse
when we are doing outlier detection or
our big models are actually not paying a
lot of attention to small classes and we
are clearly seeing this with the visible
dataset where the kind of pictures that
you see here are not are not similar to
the pictures that are in the training
data such that these models are trained
for so what do we do debugging how do we
do debugging troubleshooting for the AI
world tomorrow in the demo session I'm
going to be demoing some tools that we
are developing with our product groups
in collaboration for error analysis and
visualization what we do in these tool
sets is we get data we get error labels
so we get these data sets that have
success cases and failure cases and be
used in secret scible machine learning
techniques to separate
the successes from the failures so that
we can show developers interpretable
explanations for where for the regions
where they are seeing disproportional
errors we really think that having these
kind of tools that combine data science
with visualization and interpretability
is really important for developers to
has to have access to human feedback in
in scalable ways and really figure out
what are the next steps they should be
taking for improving their models and in
2017 besmear in Russia and us have
really focused on image captioning for
trouble showed troubleshooting and
improvement for image captioning systems
where we show that we can do
human-in-the-loop debugging and
troubleshooting truly identify what is
the most important intervention and fix
the wool uppers can do to improve these
models and we'll get into that
continuous feedback loop I talked about
and finally my third lesson from this
work is that this should be optimizing
human value not machine performance
across many different applications where
I'm seeing a lot of reliability and bias
problems I see that they are only doing
automation we are building the best
machine learning model and putting them
into the world but that does not
necessarily mean that machines are
equipped to collaborate with people to
augment them in the right way we really
don't understand what it means to build
partners we really don't understand what
it means to build AI systems that can
collaborate with people they can
understand people that can explain
themselves to people and so forth so I
think this is a very important area of
work we should be focusing on in the AI
community just make sure that we are
building machines not because we can
build cool machines but because they can
really help people so this all connects
with the work we are doing in terms of
building the engineering practices in
aih especially at a place like Microsoft
with a lot of AI products coming out to
the market and these reliability and
bias problems are real
we are thinking a lot about what are the
tool sets what are the best practices
guidelines education material we should
be providing to our engineers so that
they can build reliable trustworthy
responsible AI systems this is why we
have an internal committee at Microsoft
if you haven't heard called the ether
committee
this stands for AI epics and effects in
the engineering and research this
committee has a lot of contributions
from the research community but it's not
limited to the research community
it has representation from product
groups our legal team and together we
are trying to address some of these hard
problems so if you're interested in this
commit to work and what we are doing in
there I'm happy to talk to you so I'll
stop here and together we can take
questions thank you very much so if we
can have the panel all set up here we
can everybody can be sort of the firing
squad
that's right
so first question just back here hi
Margaret Burnett Oregon State hey I
really loved your talk we're sort of
thinking along the same lines I did some
work earlier on debugging
the sort of what the human does once
they get this feedback and that's the
part you skipped over could you just
give us a dug it of how that part works
after they've seen your visualizations
and stuff how they give feedback back
yeah that's that's a great question I'm
I really hope that you stop by at the
demo session tomorrow so that we can
have a longer conversation about about
this but the short answer is that there
is no single intervention that is gonna
work across different applications in
some cases the developer may realize
that okay this is a region that my
models are not doing a good job and I
know because my data set doesn't have
sufficient representation about these
group of users this group of users may
correspond to
she´ll or gender or age groups it may
relate to some sense to be tributes and
in that case the developer and the team
can go ahead and actually do focus data
collection and this is what happens here
at least when the gender shades paper
came out and showed problems with the
face api's however that that may not be
the solution in many cases and one thing
we've been thinking about is let's say
there is a very small and protected
group like some disability group can we
really call that scalable data from them
to be able to really expand the data set
significantly that might not be a viable
option in those cases we are looking
into things like changing the objective
function really telling the model that
this is an important group and they
should try to get the numbers up as much
as possible but even having something
like a model card that actually tells
the users and the customers these are
the things I know I'm not doing very
well please do not rely on me until I
get that you know I'm acknowledging that
I'm not very good at this
is I think another stuff you should be
doing a better job at ok yeah yeah let's
see if we can sync up afterwards so BK
thank you very much
other questions hi I'm safe Savage I'm
from West Virginia University and also
Microsoft Bing I don't know if you could
talk a little bit about the biases that
exist in how crowds are labeling data
and I also had a question about whether
you have experienced crowds using the
labeling as a sort of collective action
for instance we saw in the image of
Hillary where maybe they were labeling
as a form of maybe resistance and an
opposition to to the picture so I don't
know if you can also share about those
experiences thank you and great talks
can you hear me okay
I'll think out loud I don't have a good
canned response yet it's good question
you cannot hear can you hear me now
no okay okay okay so biases first off I
think the crowd I'm gonna put out as
lemur that I'm biased in thinking that
the crowd does really good work so I
feel that often when people complain
about the crowd it's because the person
who built the task doesn't build it in a
specified way that allows for good work
to result with that said a lot of the
tasks that I have recently posted have
been very open-ended which has revealed
certain biases in terms of so I'll give
you a specific example so we put out a
test to create a caption for an image so
given an image described and eight words
or more once in this image and if you
look at the way that and we we told the
people who are describing the images
this is for people who are blind so
trying to think about what would be
useful to that population and I show him
my slide a picture of a green shirt with
white rating on it and the caption was
very consistent across the people who
provided it which says a green shirt
with bright writing that says this
if you look at the question that the
person who submitted that image wanted
to have an answer to the question was is
this cleaner dirty and if you take a
step back and you think what would be
useful to a person that's blind that
seems pretty natural that person doesn't
want to know what's on the shirt
necessarily but wants to know is it
clean or dirty and there are so many
examples like that so I think the bias
is understanding what is useful in the
context so that's a significant bias
I've seen yeah I will just add a tiny
bit to that to say it is interesting
that you know know your user population
because we are finding in completely
different context that there are
interesting beliefs and not to say too
much in detail but you know beliefs and
things like conspiracy theories that
differ depending on what population
you're going to can I give an answer
about a bias that I've seen in card
workers so there's a data set that a
different group of researchers made
where it was language data set that was
meant for generating prediction for AAC
devices which are communication devices
that people with speech disabilities
might use like Stephen Hawking the kind
of device he used and so to create that
data set the researchers asked workers
on Mechanical Turk to imagine that they
were a person who was disabled and used
a speech generating device and to
compose some sentences about what they
might want to say and if you actually
look at that data set I think that
really shows the biases of the workers
so it's just full of really stereotyped
sentences like make me some soup I need
a blanket who will drive me to the
doctor's office which perhaps is
representative of a small subset of what
people with disabilities might want to
talk about but clearly doesn't encompass
the variety that people would have in
the real world so I think there are
actually quite a lot of examples of
biases in using Turk
oh yeah is it okay hopefully it'll be a
very simple answer to this question so
this was prompted by a Kathy's
presentation but I think it's relevant
to everybody so most of these talks it's
related to bias but a little bit
different
oh I'm Sean Kane from University of
Colorado so this work on some level kind
of assumes an objective reality that we
can largely agree upon and I'm wondering
you know how long can we coast on that
and are there places in these various
projects where that's come up so and
which is different from maybe from a
difference in perspective further
there's a little bit of anyway yeah so
how has this come up in your work right
well I actually I like the is this shirt
dirty one can imagine various
interpretations how dirty yeah I don't
know about the kind of postmodernist
visual question-answering where we are
on that progression just yet certainly
if you you can imagine asking just
straight subjective questions about
there's the you know work on fashion
advice it's highly subjective I can give
an answer I'd probably be wrong I'd
probably be objectively wrong but for
most people that's a subjective question
yeah that's I think the extent that you
know I think this is one of my worries
with respect to limiting AI to
automation rather than collaboration
when we look into AI algorithms being
used to write paragraphs or pages or
things like that do we really want
everybody to talk to the same way and
say that say the same things because if
AI algorithms are writing things that's
how things are going to be they are all
going to be conveying the same kind of
ideas unless they are really trained to
take that human idea ideation phase into
account and give the same sound and have
the same style
that's why I'm more interested in AI
technology is being used to actually
support the human ingenuity instead of
kind of take it away and just give a
single voice to people I think
that'sthat's very important and I think
that gets to the design stage more than
the training stage well but but even at
the training stage so you know one thing
we're working on is eliciting
distributional answers so you know
you're not gonna get one answer so you
just see what people say overall and
there are a couple of recent papers that
show this is a more robust way to train
machine learning systems as well don't
tell it there's a single label tell if
there's a distribution over two labels
which yeah and so to add to that so we
in our group did some work on trying to
understand why do you disagreements
happen and coming up with the taxonomy
of what are the sources and moreover we
found that when we repurpose existing
algorithms and the specific case that
was for visual questioning answering
when you take an existing state-of-art
algorithm and you try to use it to
predict why is there a disagreement you
learn that those existing algorithms
have learned to predict answers by
understanding the nuance of why
disagreement could arise and so if I
think about where should we be going as
a community I think we need to have
algorithms that have the crowd
intelligence can understand the pathways
to different possible answers and
understand when given for example an
image or a visual question there can be
multiple options and figure out what is
the right question to follow up with
someone about saying I have five
possible answers to a visual question
for example here you know help me figure
out which is the right one to give to
you so I think crowd intelligence is
what we need to start thinking about
when we think about building AI
algorithms hi I'm Jen van Gogh
University of Washington I was
interested all of you presented
different pipelines for how we get from
A to B essentially and at some level
mentioned the presence of people with
disabilities in those pipelines at the
very minimum at the end consuming what
was produced in some cases may be
generating a question and I guess my
question for you is if you think about
the entire pipeline where are the places
that you would ideally like and let's
assume not
no capacity issue in terms of how many
people are available right where are the
place that you'd want to have people
with disabilities in the pipeline how
would it change what happened for
example maybe that question of crowd
workers would have been phrased
differently in the first place or your
structured question answering would be
different in terms of getting the right
data out of crowd workers or I don't
know I'm just you've been working on
these pipelines where would you like to
see more participation from people with
disabilities and what do you think would
change a great question and my argument
is we want them at every single stage
and my argument comes from thinking
about universal design and how a lot of
innovation comes for thinking about
populations that aren't traditionally
considered so an example that I like is
the ramps that we have originally it was
built to help people with wheelchairs go
up but now people with suitcases can go
up ramps and you have many you know
strollers like mothers with kids and so
I would argue the same thing with when
we're developing captioning systems I
believe there's going to be a lot of
benefits to society at large my talk
tried to talk about the benefits of just
thinking about the images taken by
people who are blind so thinking about
data collection not as much on algorithm
generation yet and I hopefully convinced
people in the audience that there's a
lot of interesting problems that go
beyond people who are blind such as low
quality images which would happen for
example if you have a robot taking
images or privacy information I'm pretty
sure as people grow you know anyone
needs help interpreting medical
information right and then just being
able to analyze text to get there so my
argument is every stage and hopefully I
convinced you all that data collection
as a part of that that's important so I
have to agree with with that you you
definitely wanted at every stage one of
the interesting things that we sort of
naively did with our original site
system was that we wanted to have this
one we were doing bar charts but it was
a question answering you know all right
we're giving you a high level message
what
their questions would you like to ask
and the blind people people who are
blind said how do we know we never see
we have no idea how you use these we
have no idea because we've never
interacted with them so there is a
there's there's a like kind of funny
play there and that's why in part of
what we did with our system was to try
and figure out how are people that are
sighted actually using these what is it
about these visualizations that people
are pulling out and then can we figure
out how to package that so it's you
definitely want to know is that going to
be helpful but you have to be careful
that you're asking the right question a
question that makes sense for them all
right we got room we got time for maybe
one tomorrow we're over time a little
bit right now so we're eating into your
coffee break just know that so we go one
we got two questions here so let's let's
do those two questions and hopefully we
can oh I just want to make a comment so
first of all my name is Gandalf from
escape and I research institute at
Harvard Medical School and animation
about 38 meetings really impaired really
really impaired people just what just
want to point out out of those 38
millions people this is a it's a very
wide spectrum of vision impairment not
all of them are completely blind some
have a central vision loss they have a
very low B acuity some have a very few
loss they have a good view QT but the
last view so because of this their needs
gonna be very different so here all of
the speakers talking about we have to
have a human in the loop so because they
have different needs so I think that if
you try to come up with a caption one
fits all caption you you're gonna you
cannot avoid the failures so I think
very important thing is to have a human
in the loop is to have the users to
initiate in the need the question and
water gives a number of examples what
people may ask I think all of them can
be considered as a video search so the
different people have different needs so
if the AI can firstly understand the
needs of the users and then try to
interpret the image I think that may be
a good way to go it's in my opinion so
yeah it's funny choice yeah no and I
completely agree I mean I think the idea
that we've started it kind of one
extreme we're assuming a lot of this
work that it's a either completely blind
or nearly completely blind end-user in
these applications does limit that
design space right so if we had an end
user who could contribute in a different
way maybe has different set of questions
because they can make out you know
object boundaries right and so they can
direct their question in a different way
we will get very different data sets out
of this for example and there are
different potential solutions the other
thing that's interesting that didn't
come up I think in a lot of these talks
is that you can leverage the end users
understanding of the broader context
even in the case that they are totally
blind right so I think the business
example there are always these cases
where you can catch the the wrong answer
even though you don't directly have any
visual information because you asked
what is the oven set to one person said
400 one person said 450 and one person
said it's a white oven right like that
didn't help or they said egg timer it's
something that is obvious to pick out
and in business that was just left up to
the end-user interpretation right but
you could imagine actually building the
system in a way that uses the the
person's context for why they're asking
the question how the where they're
asking the question what they already
know about what the plausible set of
answers are things like that to narrow
it down without having to go out to a
crowd
independent set of labels labels I mean
I'm happy to jump on that one too I
really appreciate your comment and I
think that the nuances go beyond just
what are the wants of people in terms of
information but also the mechanism for
delivering the information so for
example people who are blind who are
literate and using technology can
actually hear at speeds much faster than
I can and so to provide content at the
way I'm speaking that would be very
irritating in technology and so I do
agree with you that having some
understanding of the context of who is
the person matters a lot and just to
make it in more abstract terms I think
we're talking about literacy so what is
for example someone's visual literacy
for example someone goes blind later in
life they might have more spatial
understanding than someone who's born
blind and someone that has a little bit
of vision might have access to some they
might have a bit more literacy and so
thank you for the comment and I couldn't
agree more we should probably wrap up
there we're already 5 minutes over so
let's give our our speakers a fabulous
round of applause and thank you all